[Musique]
c'est vraiment une couleur magnifique 0
c'est pourquoi on l'appelle le thé rouge
à sa santé
[Musique]
c'est tout douvres c'est quasiment
impossible de surin fusion dire mais oui
c'est vrai il n'ya pas d'astringence il
faut pas d'amis très sûr et on imagine
ce au froid l'été très rafraîchissant le
rooibos mot dérivé de l'african ce qui
veut dire puis son rouge est cultivé en
afrique du sud s'est dit et qui pose
dans un buisson ci pouvant intégrer en
fait botaniquement parlant c'est
vraiment considérer un buisson de part
entière mais qu'on voit une fusée
exactement comme invité il contient
d'ailleurs aucune peine aucune café donc
les gens qui sont sensibles à ça c'est
une très bonne option versus le thé ou
le café
c'est également une très bonne manière
d'initier les infusions aux jeunes
enfants parce que c'est pas un produit
qu'ils 13 à marie qui est très facile à
préparer
ça date pas d'hier qu'on s'entend c'est
vraiment en fait un buisson qu'on trouve
sur le continent africain plus
particulièrement dans le sud
et ça a existé s'est consommé depuis
plus un pl usieurs plusieurs siècles
comme en cuisine comme on est une fusion
comment mixer maison en fait les filles
vous m'avez donné en fait de cuisiner
que leur boss on va faire des madeleines
oreilles boss c'est tout s'anime a lancé
des oeufs avec tout ce qu'on veut monter
au ruban avoir des légèretés de la porte
ensuite on vos clients avec un mélange
de farine 10 m
j'adore ce long de la partie ça relève
le groupe chic pour sa part pour faire
le film adèle
[Musique]
j'ai incorporé 0,6 quand clients avec
une maryse qui on va finir ce qu'un beau
dans son lit pour les grands des mauls
on postule à vannes et par la peau de re
boss salle un peu un goût de caramel de
valeilles aussi moche trop je te donne
super savoir la porte c'est subtil mais
on sent quand même en bouche avec ses
fans de travailler mais comment vous
avez émoulu ce sont les mots lui
simplement dans un anglais un café sinon
avec un mortier
ça prend un speedboat le rooibos demande
un petit peu moins d'attention aux
détails parce que c'est une feuille qui
oxyde et est ensuite séchés tandis que
le terran voir vraiment plusieurs étapes
exemple comme lille où l'on qui part
abordé torréfaction des vieillissements
dur au tissage donc beaucoup plus simple
avait transformé le rooibos il nous
propose le csag bros parce que ça ça
devient un bon mariage entre les deux en
lice il ya la cardamome lagarde avant le
20 janv le poivre le clou de girofle la
cannelle tout en subtilité informatique
mareuil boss savoir tout ça c'est tout
est question d'équilibré qu'on va
mélanger détail les rebelles ont hissé
leur boss est là comme ça c'est très
parfumée je suis simplement y ait des
écorces de pamplemousse d'orange et de
la cardamome verte aussi avec c'est
vraiment et on sent vraiment les agrumes
ou cool ça vous inspire quoi
maintenant on va faire un beau mec est
un créneau chocolat noir qui est en fait
une panacotta dans lequel on a mis de
chocolat noir mais et moi je fais ce que
j'ai refusé soit du thé du café des
agrumes on et faisait froid avec j'ai
pris ma crème on est minuté à
l'intérieur puis on laisse infuser 24
heures au frigo
ce que ça permet de faire en fait ça va
pas développer l'amertume
on va avoir le goût du thé le goût des
agrumes mais sans la de l'amertume
désagréable
avoir une foi et fusées 24 heures
isabelle filtre la crème au tamis avant
de la faire chauffer et l'ajouter au
chocolat et à la gélatine
elle verse dans des pots pour faire
figer la panna cotta au frigo pendant
six heures en garniture un crumble de
chocolat noir avec suprêmes d'orange et
de kumquats donnera un peu d'acidité et
de beauté
c'est plus utile parce qu'on l'a et
faisait à froid aussi
pas comme un goût mais c'est vraiment ce
type yale crumble puis chez les agrumes
qui viennent jouer aussi j'aurais
tendance à dire que qui est comme une
petite amertume qui peut se rapprocher
du chocolat devrait probablement aussi
du rooibos recensés soit envahissant
puisse on est vraiment fan de reuil bost
on peut faire une panacotta tout 500
chauffeurs juste crémerie bosse avec
l'on veut vraiment voir le bout de plus
prononcée du bost je faisais beaucoup
déjà que le match et le thé rue et tout
ce j'ai encore pas beaucoup des thé le
café tous dans mais pas de frime et leur
boss était une première
gillot à la lumière de ce que ça donne
comme résultat vous pourriez faire autre
chose on pourrait essayer de le piller
les maisons dit ça donne vraiment un
goût de vanille avec ce jeu rare amusé
avec 6 dans les pâtes à gâteaux tout
simple ou même les biscuits des sondés
s'apprêtent intéressant aussi un petit
sablé où il bosse comme un conte sur
normal à cet agrume de danse apprend que
le fun aussi nogué ça m'a ouvert une
porte à beaucoup de créativité pour le
prochain
[Musique]